The Joe Rogan Experience man it's
interesting watching these guys
come and go and you know and come in
with so much promise and it doesn't
doesn't quite
you know injuries yeah this enjoy Darren
Taylor had a bunch of knee injuries yeah
well you know the UFC is a is a
promotion machine so they sell the world
a dream for each and every one of us you
know what I mean so a lot of people out
there in the world have this have this
idea of me that you know could be
completely wrong you know what I mean so
um we all have these expectations
everybody has these hopes and and dreams
and stuff like that and us as far as
especially with the mics in front of our
face are allowed to share ours so
everybody definitely believes us when we
say what believes me when I say I'm
going to be a champion one day you know
what I mean I seriously believe myself
when I say that so um
but very few of us are going to make it
to that to that level you know what I
mean a very few percentage of us are
going to make it so that's the reality
of it you know
um and that's the reality I had already
come to terms when I first started this
so when I first started doing uh MMA I
already had a full-time job a good
comfortable job you know what I mean
um I was able to take care of my family
so I was good and I was able to go train
so I was happy
um I just told myself I'm just gonna go
as far as I can go you know what I mean
um
pretty much make myself no promises you
know what I mean because I understand
that I understand my ability and I had
confidence in myself which is why I did
it in the first place but I understand
the reality of it and I should be and I
was blessed to have already have a
full-time job to be able to take care of
myself because there's a lot of Fighters
a lot of Fighters out there are broke
trying to fight yeah you know the
majority of majority of Fighters are in
broke situations trying to fight so
um
yeah when I first when I was training it
wasn't my goal to be a UFC fighter I
just wanted to go as far as I can learn
as much as I can while I have this time
here on Earth
so just as far as I've gotten well
you've gotten pretty [__] far yeah
you've got a great approach man you got
a great approach to life a great
approach to this this path that you're
on to to be a better martial artist and
a better person like that that's uh it's
it's it's a fascinating approach it's a
very Samurai like you know I think it is
I do take I take for me I like to take
energies from all places and try to
create this I don't want to say
character but create this Avatar and
equip this Avatar with all these
different perks and stuff that I find
admirable that I find moral and things
that's going to make me a bigger
stronger better what am I a human right
a man right a black man if we want to
use those labels and terms you know what
I mean but uh for me being who I am and
uh that's a great way to think about it
yeah and not necessarily try to
distinguish myself from any and
everybody else you know what I mean look
to any and everybody else to see the
potential that I have because we're all
human we all have the potential to do
great and wonderful things or terrible
and
bad things you know what I mean I tell
you I said this is one thing I tell my
children my children you know we have
the ability as humans this is what makes
us unique from any other species on this
planet that we have the ability to be an
animal
or we can be something better than that
we have the ability to be a demon or a
devil or we can be a Celestial or a God
or a goddess you know what I mean
not that we would physically embody our
definitions of these things these are
just conceptualizations but
I think for me that allows me to take
the trajectory of my life and point it
to where I want I want to ascend you
know what I mean to concept to use the
word that has been so conceptualized to
godhood and I realize that I'm not
V Almighty but I am living a uh
an aspect I am
generating a perspective I am
so many different ways to put it
living in experience you know what I
mean that God can look back and say yep
I've done this you know what I mean
maybe this has already been done maybe
it hasn't but
for me I just want to go up be better I
want to be able to levitate and [__]
like that you know what I mean yeah do
things that nobody else does which is
probably one of the reasons why I joined
the army and do martial arts in the
first place because everybody where I'm
from where I grew up definitely wasn't
joining the Army and nobody was doing
martial arts that I knew of so um
I guess I was just born a
non-conformist if you will
and I just like taking a route that I
find best suits me
you feel me yeah I do feel you yeah no
that's a fascinating path I like what
you just said I'd like I like what you
just said a lot yeah I think if people
could adopt that mindset and adopt that
way of thinking I think that would be
very very beneficial to a lot of people
yeah it's very admirable sometimes when
you hear someone's philosophy the way
they think about things and the way they
approach their life you go oh that's
admirable and that's what I just felt
when you're saying that I was like
that's that's very admirable I I like
when someone has a a very clear
disciplined sort of view of what their
life is and what they're trying to
accomplish and you have especially with
this mindset that you have about
constant growth about looking at like
that like you're always on the path yeah
and and to approach that as a martial
artist and then you know be a martial
artist while you're still an elite
fighter in the UFC yeah but you're still
a martial artist and I think that's why
you're so good